lumineuse brillante encore à l'aube de
sa vie n'a remis kurosaki avait tout à
espérer de l'avenir elle a disparu corps
et biens de sa chambre universitaire une
nuit de décembre 2016 une énigme que des
milliers d'heures de recherches n'ont
toujours pas élucidées la dépouille de
la jeune japonaise reste introuvable
pour sa famille le procès à venir est
sans doute la dernière chance de savoir
ce qui est arrivé à celle dont ils ne
peuvent faire le deuil il me disait un
que au delà de la vérité dont il n'est
ce pas remonte peut-être même plus
qu'elle soit délivrée c'était plus une
révélation sur le lieu du finalement où
est enterré le corps de narumi ou en
tout cas je dis enterré mais finalement
c'est une supputation parce que
naturellement ne sais pas ce qu'ils
étaient devenus de ce corps et qu' il
n'y a que nicolas zepeda qui détient les
réponses à ce sujet et ils sont donc
dans cette perspective aussi de
supplique de de demande pour pouvoir
faire part de leur chagrin et puis
expliquer à quel point justement de ces
cette problèmatique d'absence de corps
pour eux et douloureuse et un est
insurmontable en terme de souffrance
tout va donc se passer ici dans le
creuset de la cour d'assises de besançon
une cour d'assises qui se prépare
minutieusement depuis des semaines voire
des mois pour un procès atypique débat
trilingue duplex en direct du bout du
monde pour une affaire qui intéresse
trois continents
jurés français
victimes japonaises accusent les
chiliens trois pays pour une même quête
de vérité que ce soit à santiago du
chili lors de l'audition préalable à
l'extradition ou face aux juges
d'instruction français nicolas cepeda
n'a jamais s'étaient bousculés pas de
garde à vue pas de contre-interrogatoire
non pas le fact beaucoup de questions ne
lui ont pas encore été posée et beaucoup
de réponses donc n'ont pas été apportées
par nicolas zappellaz qui restaient dans
une zone de confort il va devoir sortir
aux assises de cette zone de confort et
ça il ne sait pas il n'a pas été mis à
l'épreuve pour l'instant et les preuves
réelles c'est la cour d'assises les
preuves de sa version c'est la cour
d'assises les preuves de ses réponses la
qualité de ses réponses c'est la cour
d'assises et ça pour l'instant il est
très confortablement dans le processus
judiciaire positionné avec très peu de
contradiction
devant la cour d'assises avait
différents il va falloir convaincre
absence de corps absence d'aveux
l'accusation aussi il va devoir
convaincre pour les parties civiles tout
mais néanmoins au fils de bonne famille
quelles que soient ses dénégations on en
serait d'ailleurs pas là aujourd'hui sur
une un procès d'assises ou amène
antérieurement sur une extradition s'il
n'y avait pas vu dans ce dossier chien
une convergence d'éléments qui nous
démontre que l'absence de corps n'est
pas du tout faux le synami qu'il n'y a
pas eu de geste criminel il y a
effectivement un certain nombre
d'éléments
qui de façon univoque non pas permettre
de penser mais permettre d'être certain
qu'on a donné la mort à narumi après et
dans des conditions qui sont des
conditions criminelle deuxièmement on
s'est débarrassé de son cadavre je
n'utilise bien le mot cadavres
après on a des éléments qui permettent
d'imputer ces faits-là à nicolas zepeda
nicolas cepeda at-il prémédité son geste
comme le laisse penser la soigneuse
planification de son voyage en france
peut-il craqué sous la pression et a
voué à minima l'accident l'homicide
involontaire ou bien comme il l'a
toujours fait jusqu'à présent ce terreau
at-il laissant son avocate opposé des
explications à chaque élément de preuve
tout peut arriver et parce que la
présomption d'innocence reste la règle
parce que le doute doit toujours
profiter à l'accusé l'acquittement fait
partie des hypothèses
la famille de n'a remis sa maman
notamment on ne peut pas imaginer un
seul instant qu'il y à un acquittement
c'est au delà de ce qui est possible
dans sa souffrance de mer depuis je
rappelle que au japon à la peine de mort
et continue à être appliquée donc il ya
eu de vrai questionnement aussi sur
l'issue d'un procès ici en france et sur
ce que pouvait représenter une peine
pénale et et l'absence de peine de mort
ici en france
qu'est-il arrivé à narumi nicolas zepeda
est-il un meurtrier
les réponses appartiennent désormais à
l'intimé conviction des jurés